Averell was trying to factor 6x squared
minus 18x plus 12 she found that the
greatest common factor of these terms
was 6 and made an area model what is the
width of Averill's area model so pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out and then we'll work through
this together alright so there's a
couple of ways to think about it she's
trying to factor 6x squared minus 18x
plus 12 and she figured out that the
greatest common factor was 6 so one way
she could you could think about it is
this could be rewritten as 6 times
something else and to help her think
about it she thought about an area model
where if you had a rectangle if you had
a rectangle like this and if the height
is 6 and the width let's just call that
2 width for now so this is the width
right over here if you multiply 6 times
the width and maybe I could write with
right over here if you multiply 6 times
the width you multiply the height times
the width you're going to get the area
so imagine that the area of this
rectangle was our original expression 6x
squared minus 18x plus 12 and that's
exactly what's drawn here now what's
interesting is is that they broke up the
area into three sections
this pink section is the 6x squared this
blue section is the negative 18x and
this peach section is the 12 and of
course these aren't drawn to scale
because we don't even know how wide each
of these are because we don't know what
X is so this is all a little bit
abstract but this is a show that we can
break our bigger area into three smaller
areas and what's useful about this is we
could think about the width of each of
these sub areas and then we can add them
together to figure out the total width
so what is the width of this pink
section right over here well 6 times
what is 6 x squared well 6 times x
squared is 6 x squared so the width here
is x squared now what about this blue
area a height of 6 times what width is
equal to negative 18 X so let's see if I
take 6 times negative 3i
get negative 18 but then I have to
multiply it times an X as well to get
negative 18 X so 6 times negative 3x is
negative 18 X and then last but not
least 6 our height of 6 times what is
going to be equal to 12 well 6 times 2
is equal to 12 so we figured out the
widths of each of these sub regions and
now we know what the total width is the
total width is going to be our x squared
plus our negative 3x plus r2 so the
width is going to be x squared and I can
just write that as minus 3x plus 2 so we
have answered the question and you could
substitute that back in for this and you
could see if you multiplied 6 times all
of this if you distributed the 6 you
would indeed get 6x squared minus 18x
plus 12